you
efore Issa 'kx b3 d5 Bishop b2 D takes
e4 and that I've had played against me
you know who plays that someone on the
ICC plays that quite a bit
oh the term is just starting a player on
the ICC - Wang Yu plays that b3 stuff
quite a bit alright we're gonna we're
gonna go undefeated here we're gonna
play like a machine I'm gonna try to
play like a machine I'm gonna damage our
structure and everything all right let's
castle I've got a challenge that night
you know it's too strong
he's beastly all right Knight you got to
make a decision hold on with this my
queen they'll have a fine post all right
I'm okay with this structure yeah we're
gonna expand a little bit this pawn
slinky going did he just say pawn slinky
he did my king is gonna creep over push
there that move alright I have another
sneaky idea in mind get my king over
here okay not a lot of time I could
actually do this because their King is
really out of play and this is a one
King and pawn ending let's do this first
good night is this working out yeah oh
Yunis they're really in time I guess it
was not working our oh they have that
check even I could exchange Queens and
still win yeah cuz I get this one now
I'm in time
no stalemates it took two queens it took
the promotion of two queens for that one
uh every fan wants to clean that right
now that's that's a sign of some serious
aggression h3 what's the fear right in
black Oh get out man oh oh that's a
piece triple pawns temporarily okay
where's the open file there it is
alright let's poke around over here f5
Knight g5 oh yeah there we go
d 6 e 6 holes get there they're
important gonna play this move just to
make sure this bond doesn't hurt me next
up and Bishop b4 bringing the pain
possible discoveries Knight moves let's
pick him off probably wasn't best
actually there's even a pin going on
pawn takes Knight is not available I
could do this first make use of the fact
that my knight is there to defend and
only now jump in here they're also down
on time let's scoop that pawn up and
go here and then when the Queen
maybe the rook where is the mate
anything there down on time back to
terminal and I have four and I'm just
out of page one
plenty of time left okay another new
another first time playing against
someone already let's just give up on
wasn't I wasn't planned i blundered it
and then tried to cover up by saying
yeah let's just give up on four zero
compensation yeah
gonna play before everything is pointing
at before what's the what's the delay
my queen wants to be on f8 trying to
maneuver already my nights gonna be on
f6 soon mm-hmm let's see we get here
queen is defended by my night so I could
do this and drop upon yeah doing okay on
the clock dangerous night okay hmm
I'm not even threatening that pawn their
night moves might be interesting trouble
forks I keep pushing
dropped a piece ah they're crumbling now
dropping material and they went into the
think tank on that one they had a clear
pawn up but it's never easy against a
knight keeps you on your toes that's how
this guy talks about man just talks
about that night he has a lot of respect
for that night doesn't he and it's
thrown in between her in there okay
I'd see five hits
let's stop Knight c5 oh here
c5 was scaring me okay interesting
super backward pawn here maybe I can
make use of c4 they're gonna get to c3
where's the fork 95 I guess Knight f6 is
coming let's get my knight in the center
no don't know if that was best but we're
gonna try to be sneaky okay it's a clean
in attack their queen I have a good spot
to go to though that's a check
I'll take with the Queen
I have mass exchanges I have two
connected get pigs
I got pigs and we got me back determined
that final position wasn't me but it was
going to lead to me I have 12 17 16 15
12 am on fire so another win and I'd be
at 16 a lot of time left
okay can I get a quick win in we try
with that for these games are taken too
long I'm gonna challenge this Bishop
take their first make sure I could
damage their structure now takes try to
peel open the F file alright they're
giving me something to work with the
light squares Knight C to G for Queen D
for check I could block with Knight f2
and B securing everything I might get
play against this pawn bishop here hmm
interesting move they are no longer
defending up six so if the knight moves
on pushing I like my position here take
with the rook I need to keep defense
over this guy c6 defends the knight
laterally oh they have that move Queen
takes e4 I guess they don't see Queen
takes e4 I don't want to take the knight
I'm gonna play here against their dark
squares Bishop h6 stuff they're Knights
now and a pin I don't know I don't know
how many time we're gonna sack I haven't
Queen here my rook is still in a pin
let's just crawl up into a ball they
don't have any time back to tournament
21 2016 Harrell Ralph okay let's push
him around no okay let's get on this for
c4 yeah let's do it
get out of there
hmm interesting
I'm gonna take this Knight out though
yeah because there's a pretty serious
pin yeah they resigned it's pretty quick
maybe they would have something if I
took and they were able to get over the
h-file but just crashing show just
sitting with my pawn on h6 keeping them
in a pin drunk mode alright well still
wrong with that for a little bit let's
keep some space
a need for strong maybe they had d3
don't know if I could have taken their
night here I have Knight d6 that's what
they're covering all right let's open up
the that's a pond maybe make them
struggle to get it back I don't think he
could be hunted down so easily Queen f7
Knight here you know so it's a fork and
if they take I have a connected past
pawn Queen here I could push Queen c7 I
have Knight g5 there in the think tank
it's trouble for team black 26:24 I'm at
20 still 13 minutes left in this one
less than 10 when I just check to see if
I got hit with the Comcast gambit they
are timed out
30 29 24 17 133 are in this one okay
let's try for a BOGO alright my defy
pawn is gonna be trying to restrict that
night for one and let's get this in okay
I'm winning some material here I won the
beep on there knight on f3 is frozen he
moves I take the knight on D - let's
take and defend this guy oh they missed
I was on the Queen I guess they're going
to resigned here they resigned back to
tournament that was pretty quick 34:29
28:19
okay less than 12 minutes remained call
it 34 34 28 I am six back I think he
just yeah I was just ready to say I
thought he was he just finished all
right so last time he saddled me with
I see pond that was backward let's try
let's do this huh they're still gonna
get me with the backwards see pond but
let's go with this just to inject some
little variety in there in the position
you know that nights super strong no
doubt okay hanging on by a thread and
that is all
let's take with the pond control this
square they're still functioning on the
dark squares hmm I don't think they have
my night my pond is pretty dangerous no
hmm I think I could dislodge their night
hmm I up a pond yep they got me
hmm and also on the clock yeah it's too
easy to play I should resign yeah my
bishop was a bad bad man
mmm okay let's go with efore hmm yeah
that was very positionally weak on my
end that was bad I dropped that pawn I
thought I could undermine their night
position
exchange in Queens all right let's grab
a tempo against this Bishop first and we
grab some space let's throw this check
in I'm threatening knight c6 I could
secure my d4 point okay Bishop d2 King
on d3 might be pretty good my knight
needs to reposition right here I only
want to trade one rook and then get in
this f5 idea my knight is really good I
have to offset their knight Knight a5 b3
let's go at c5
excuse me f5
now he's weakened even have sex soon
with rook f6 to follow my rook is super
active now hitting the night hitting
everything really you know they missed
that they resigned back to tournament
less than eight forty three forty two
thirty hmm that's tough that's a tough
mountain to climb all right we might get
fluff fried liver stuff not quite let's
try this let's go Queen side I want to
see h3 they're coming at me I'm gonna
push
I push in the center okay
go here Oh f4 I feel like I just want to
keep pushing here H 4 H 3 Manji - why do
they defend that Queen D - I guess no
they didn't defend it back - terment 47
40 - 30 - less than 7 this guy's been on
a roll
aside from his first round game oh is
that a mouse slip f6 and a queenside
castle maybe get a little weakness in
there of there dark squares taken
they're all ready to take they could
take my queen wits check they just gave
me their dark square bishop who cares
about that
I'm the rook oh this is really dangerous
I could deal with that I think no I
can't
oh that was bad
and that was really bad oh boy
can I get out of this Knight takes pawn
Wow mm-hmm um I guess my Kings gonna
have to pack up and run huh 32 seconds
run king fast they could win exchange
and stuff with this not doing that
though Queen close - trapped
got their queen lucky lucky lucky their
bishop they resigned back determine y
Ike's who these two guys took a hit 47
42 36 I have fire but is there enough
time this guy's playing I might get
paired up no thought I might get picked
paired up with zip it again all right
let's go for c5 Queen b6 that was a very
ugly game in that last one that Bishop
off the dog and I'll throw the knight in
there let's take out that watch over the
e4 break I have my queen
yeah thought I might do that okay my
knight hopefully can be a pest here we
go how about we play caveman style
caveman style coming up King there
rook g8 g5 a night there abort abort
well maybe not could still crash through
with this
let's just get rid of that pawn
and now defend right at least I made him
think oh that wasn't good that was
definitely not good they're down a time
back determine 49 4440 it's free minutes
left I'm only gonna get two more games
in do I have to go berserk no matter who
I play against okay one more game
definitely but can I get two in all
right I think they miss played it cuz
this guy is now cooked well they
resigned really quick no breakdown their
dark squares they're gonna break down
mine all right we're gonna go Queen side
I think that's the safest bet where are
they going pollen hunting and I guess
Queen c5 get rid of their night all
right dark square bishop
hang on to that pawn clamp down on this
structure Oh rook takes Bishop you goof
they didn't see it they had ripped takes
bishop
King close to mated I think he is
painting to threat I may have won back
to tournament minute 29 can I sneak in
one more can I sneak into second a
minute 22 I don't know out of a
caro-kann I'd take mine
take on d4 okay let's open up this
position you're gonna go h5 break up in
the center 58 seconds that pawn is
pinned and let's try here the Queen
check let's get rid of that night my
knight is pinned I got to get out of
that pin hook up and over
Knight here now is no oh yeah I have
that in between move fortunately
all right I should be able to win on
time but this game is not gonna finish
oh it's a one King and pawn ending or is
it yikes
let's make him struggle first a little
bit more and let's clamp down on this
guy first get this pawn a little further
advanced before I finally commit now
we're gonna take get this guy and now
here here and then I'll be able to push
through a g5 actually there's a better
way to do this now am i pushing through
I am okay they're down on time but I was
nowhere close to sneaking that last one
in finished up 5347 4438 a hundred and
sixty were in this one thirty six twenty
eight twenty seven
let's see who else was in that one
Magnus Kasparov twelve was in there
all right to the 160 of you but I say
good games on the last one good games
all
you